hey guys we'll get to this next clip in
a second first I want to tell you about
one of our sponsors it's one of the most
ambitious RPG projects of 2019 it's just
been released
it's called raid Shadow legends playing
raid is one of the most immersive
experiences you'll find on a smartphone
and the best part is it's totally free
raid has everything you'd expect from a
brand new RPG title like an amazing
storyline awesome graphics player versus
player battles but it's much better than
anything you would likely expect from a
mobile game and if you download the game
through my link which you can find under
this video you'll not only be helping to
support the david pakman show but you'll
immediately get extra in-game perks like
50,000 silver coins and a free epic
champion go check it out let's talk
about North Korea Donald Trump is
removing sanctions on North Korea not
because they've actually done anything
good but because Donald Trump likes
North Korean dictator Kim jong-un there
are two interpretations that we could
have of Donald Trump's dealings with
North Korea so far the more optimistic
one is hey listen Trump hasn't gone to
war with North Korea and that's good and
we should just be happy about it the
more realistic explanation is that every
single one of trumps interactions with
North Korea has been as ignorant as it's
been disturbing claiming victory after
that first failed summit in Singapore as
we saw North Korea continue to develop
weapons believing that Trump had
accomplished something by securing a
meeting with Kim jong-un was completely
embarrassing even though anyone who
understands the history of American
North Korean relations knows that North
Korean leaders have always been willing
to meet with American presidents it's
the American presidents who have
realized we're not going to give them
the PR benefit of a meeting unless there
are some preconditions then Trump going
and having a second set of negotiations
which ended once again with no progress
and an abrupt end with absolutely no
advancement whatsoever but maybe the
most concerning element of this entire
thing has been
the dealings that Trump has had with Kim
jong-eun are yet another data point of
Trump liking authoritarians and
dictators but increasingly not getting
along with Western democracies that have
been historically allied with the United
States of America when you look at
France and Canada and the UK and Germany
our relationships with those countries
have been noticeably worsening under the
presidency of Donald Trump and yet
praise from Trump for Putin and in some
senses for Assad for Diwan
for duterte for Xi and more recently for
Kim jong-un and now Donald Trump is
going further in his praise he's
actually justifying removing sanctions
on North Korea simply because he likes
Kim jong-un I guess on some kind of
personal level last week Trump's
administration announced new sanctions
on companies that helped North Korea
avoid sanctions on them and Trump
announced the next day via a tweet that
those sanctions are being immediately
canceled saying quote it was announced
today by the US Treasury that additional
large-scale sanctions would be added to
those already existing sanctions on
North Korea I have today ordered the
withdrawal of those additional sanctions
now why the sudden reversal just one day
after the sanctions were announced to
begin with well Donald Trump with Donald
Trump's press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders was asked about it she said it's
because Trump likes Kim jong-un she was
asked about this and his quoted as per
the White House press pool report
President Trump likes chairman Kim by
the way even using that term chairman
part of the problem and he doesn't think
these sanctions will be necessary Trump
is going against the best assessments of
his own administration to appease Kim
jong-un for no reasonable geopolitically
valid reason whatsoever
there has been no end
that Kim jong-un has any actual interest
in disarmament there's no indication
that came jong-un has any actual
interest in human rights reforms which
by the way Trump said at least that his
first summit he didn't even bring up to
Kim jong-un and then you have to
consider the degree of disconnect that's
happening in Trump's administration his
Treasury Department presumably worked
for a long time a whole bunch of people
work together hours hours hours putting
together these additional sanctions they
announced them and then the next day
Donald Trump says no we don't need that
because I like Kim jong-un American
foreign policy is being run on Trump's
uninformed whims and in particular it's
the whims that favor and are impressed
by brutal authoritarian dictator after
brutal authoritarian dictator imagine
just for a second if Barack Obama had
done something like this and in fact you
don't even really have to imagine it
because during the 2008 presidential
campaign Barack Obama merely said I'd be
open to meeting with some of our enemies
Fox News lost it anti-american Rush
Limbaugh absolutely lost it
Trump not only did it he did it without
preconditions he was totally bamboozled
he claimed victory which was immediately
demonstrated not to be a victory and for
whatever reason I think we know why
called partisanship right-wing media
says it's good we should be trying to
get along with people rather than
arguing or or being on bad terms well
why didn't you apply that to President
Obama why did you make it a bigger
scandal when Obama wore a tan suit or
picked the wrong kind of mustard for a
sandwich or a burger or something those
were bigger scandals on the right then
Donald Trump meeting with Kim jong-un
without preconditions falling hook line
and sinker for the same games that North
Korean leaders have been playing for
decades and now Donald Trump says you
know what I like the guy I don't think
we need any new sanctions on North Korea
it's a bad time very very bad time for
geopolitics in terms of the role and the
position that the United States of
America has make sure
you follow the show on Instagram at
David Pakman show while you're there
follow me I'm on Instagram at David
Pakman coming up next much-anticipated
interview with Natalie win of Contra
points Fame